people think they know my story but this
is our story
just need a second coach you're on the
team here nah but I could be if you're
lucky me and my boys we've been balling
with each other since we was like 10.
call ourselves a Fab Four
you can win US state championship
guaranteed
sacrifice muscle pay the price I mean
we're young I was just trying to find
good kids they all kind of balanced each
other out Willie both his parents
addicts his big brother took him in
saved his little brother's life she uh
we just want to see how to work off a
little bit of this baby fat Drew was
born with basketball in his blood
I picked LeBron because he has skills
and he was a good kid his mom just wants
the spot where he can be safe and not
get me any trouble come on
we value all the talent you boys are
going to bring to this school oh my
goodness look at y'all and not tell me
which one are y'all supposed to be
Carlton
um
they're not very good let's try this
you're in the game let's go
we may be seeing the beginnings of
something special here
watch out you watch out maybe you see
some new faces this is Mr Travis Travis
you're so damn good and they know it
your business
make sure that doesn't tear them apart
what's it like coaching the best high
school player in the country
play some defense
sorry can't all be composed to me how
successful you become depends on how
well you manage pressure
it's not just your player he's your son
too so we just ain't gonna talk to each
other for the whole season
what happens if nobody wants me a whole
lot more than just basketball
I wanted to make great players out here
Dad wants to make green man that'll last
a lot longer
we here cause we know we'll be capable
of
when you look back at this time in your
lives it won't be the stats
to be that person next to you
did you make the time you had together
right now I'm not thinking about the
future I'm thinking about my brothers
[Applause]
all my life